this is a black smoker one of the most
inhospitable habitats on earth searing
heat total darkness crushing pressure
with the help of remotely operated
vehicles scientists are just beginning
to understand it their newest tool
virtual reality that's right
deep-sea VR the deepest VR of all in
March scientists with the Schmidt Ocean
Institute observe this vent 3,600 feet
deep near Samoa for a rather thorough
150 hours the ROV took VR video allowing
the scientists aboard the research
vessel Falkor to actually look around
with a headset they even uploaded the
360 degree video to YouTube so everyone
can get in on the action the ROV also
digitally mapped the black smoker that
helps researchers pinpoint spots they
want to explore instead of just digging
around willy-nilly if the team ever
returns to the vent that can remap it to
see how it's changed over time back on
land scientists can use this data to do
their own research in the comfort of
their labs and they're working fast
because deep-sea mining companies also
have their eye on the vents you see when
water seeped into the seafloor
underlying magma heats it up as this
water churns it picks up minerals like
copper and rare earth metals
if mining companies decide to go after
these minerals the black smokers might
never look the same again
but with the help of 3d mapping and VR
scientists will always have a
comprehensive picture of this beautiful
and bizarre ecosystem
so grab your VR headset and take a deep
dive it's just like being there without
you know the instant death